j'ai tout de suite vu au moment où tu as
passé la porte que tu avais ce petit
quelque chose en plus ce supplément
d'âme tu es une vraie star
j'en ai marre qu'on se produisent sur
l'équipe ten de nashville un peu les
plus grands
[Musique]
donc il est encore tôt vous allez mettre
le feu quelque part les fonds a le temps
de récupérer mon sac
[Musique]
c'est harper deutsch lee et moi on est
obsédé par les deux chefs titeuf c'est
sa maison ouais
et si je te disais que j'ai l'adresse de
parfer deutsch et tu l'as eu comment
caleb me la donner
ouais ça m'étonnerait
va se pointer chez est comme ça
[Musique]
ça
donc vous voulez que je fasse une
chanson avec vous
vous êtes doué on pourrait vous montrer
lequel des deux est la meilleure on est
pareil on a commencé par boire
et comme as avec harper d'aix c'est une
excellente idée
après la fête
[Musique]
c'est bizarre je suis presque sûr que
harper a tué au
c'est pas vrai
et cette montée lui le contre l'autre
c'est ma maison ça me dérange pas de la
pulvériser pour vous trouver
les filles sont passées sur un coup de
tête pour me demander des conseils mais
on se crée rien n'est gratuit à
nashville
sa mère
[Musique]